[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
i present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello pups
jumping keepers
an almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
i will be right here when you get back
pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody wants to be a somebody but
i want to be real why on earth would you
want to be real when you can be
famous
[Music]
nokia should have been home by now
you won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
pinocchio
be brave
[Music]
truthful
not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person pinocks
oh what's happening jiminy looks like
some sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
[Music]
starlight star bright
first star i see tonight
i wish i may
i wish i might
have the wish
i wish tonight
when you wish upon a start
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you